hey leute was genau herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video ja leute schafft
natürlich stets gut bevor dieses wieder
losgeht ich kann euch sofort am anfang
sagen es wird echt ein richtig heftiges
video ich denke habe ich ein titel auch
schon gelesen bevor wir anfangen muss
ich noch einiges dazu erklären und ja
ich würde sagen ich bin nicht angelaufen
fangen wir an also leute ich muss euch
mal kurz was zeigen vielleicht kann sich
aber noch der ein oder andere dran
erinnern und zwar ich muss mal kurz
gucken wann das war so ungefähr vor
einem jahr habe ich glaub ich das letzte
video dazu hochgeladen und zwar waren
das hier war so experimente das hier ist
läuft das krasseste gewesen das kann man
auf mittlerweile gar nicht mehr angucken
15 und 18 ist obwohl ich eigentlich
durchgehend drogen richtig niedergemacht
habe also eigentlich sollte man daraus
lernen auch hier alkoholkonsum vor
zuschauern das allererste video dazu das
war das hier und zwar ja ich rauche
experiment es war einfach so eine idee
von mir und ich hab einfach so richtig
lag eigentlich so eine zigarette
genommen um ihren mund gesteckt ich
meine da war ich noch nicht so
professionell wie jetzt hat das dann
einfach auf snapshot hochgeladen und die
reaktionen gefilmt und eigentlich
wirklich jeder sofort checken müssen
dass das fake ist ich mein guckt euch
dieses foto mal an wenn du das schaf
stellen würde guckt euch das mal an ja
dass ich jetzt mal auf das video drauf
das kam am 19 2 und 2016 also fast zwei
jahre her ich glaube das war einst mit
meiner ersten videos die schon so
ziemlich polarisiert haben und auch echt
abgegangen sind also der ein oder andere
von euch sollte dieses video auf jeden
fall kennen ja aber das ganze ist ja
mittlerweile so um die zwei jahre fast
her deswegen werden sich die meisten
denke ich nicht mehr daran erinnern und
da ich das wirklich so krass finde ich
meinen wenn ihnen youtuber rauf und das
sagt das ist ja mal echt so richtig war
dass das geht eigentlich nicht und ich
zum beispiel ich bin ja mittlerweile
jetzt auch nicht mehr so jung aber was
so rauchen angeht ich konnte das noch
nie ab wirklich ich finde es schmeckt
absolut scheiße und wieso sollte ich
jeden tag zum 506 euro für so einen
dreck skippen schachtel ausgeben ich
meine das sind im jahr fast 3000 euro ja
da wir auch wirklich sehr sehr viele von
meinen freunden und so weiter rauchen
was geht habe ich mir für heute so eine
art reloaded experiment überlegt und
dafür müssen jetzt ausmisten und
zigaretten kaufen ich habe das jetzt in
meinem leben zweimal gebrochen gekauft
weil ich die irgendwie mitbringen sollte
und heute ist das dritte mal und heute
benutze ich das wirklich für mich selber
und
leute was dann auf jeden fall noch
hinzukommen damals als ich das bei
snapshot gepostet habe hatte ich glaube
ich weiß nicht dazu 4000 follower
mittlerweile sehen wir eine story halter
so 40.000 das heißt ja nochmal viel mehr
reaktionen darauf und ja also ich war
alles los war schon zu viel gelabert wir
sehen uns gleich so leute bei mir läuft
richtig habe jetzt was wir kaufen muss
nicht mal auswärts zeigen vor allem das
lustige ist ich glaube vor zwei jahren
als das video gemacht habe weiß ich
macht sein aber jetzt bin ich acht sind
das heißt es sogar egal
ich brauche die noch alle nichtraucher
geben jetzt von dort nach oben und ganz
am ende verbrenne ich die no
nein nein ich glaube brennen die ganze
schachtel safe
so leicht ich bin jetzt hier an seinem
werk so mitten im nirgendwo fast also
hier ist zumindest fast nichts und ich
muss mich ein bisschen beeilen weil das
wird schon gleich dunkel aber wir machen
jetzt ein cooles blick für meinen
instagram sorry also ich habe mich
einmal diese zigaretten gekauft und noch
ein feuerzeug ich werde es gleich einmal
kurz rauchen oder vielleicht zwei mal
und deshalb auch foto festhalten dann
posten auch ein zaun was passiert also
ich würde das dann mal so zwei schon
drin lassen dass werden locker so 20.000
menschen sehen und mal gucken wie die
reaktion darauf ist weil dieses mal
lasse ich das wirklich real aussehen das
letzte experiment so in diese richtung
ist jetzt auch schon so fast ein jahr
her deswegen denke ich dass viele nicht
mehr an sowas denken und dann will ich
mal gespannt
auf kind gibt es kein trick
alex klicken auf
das rauchen aufgeben für ihre lieben
weiterleben also leute merkt euch das
ich finde das stimmt schon so allein und
wenn man nicht mehr daran zieht hier
habe ich jetzt eine zigarette
das ist so brutal eklig
so leute werden jetzt erstmal sofort uns
und zwar dass hier das aber noch
ziemlich lasch also da kann man ja nicht
viel das könnte wieder krank sein dass
post jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal sofort
in meine snapshot story und hier habe
ich jetzt noch die krasse und fotos die
bringe ich euch einfach mal kurz ein
aber vor es jetzt weitergeht mit euren
ganzen rezensionen die er mir
hoffentlich hab meins nadschaf
öffentlich müssen wir erst mal auf diese
drecks packung verbrennen also leute
wenn ihr raucht tut mir den gefallen
hört bitte auf danke
bringt das laster in brand
so leute wieder sauber das kommt jetzt
soweit ich habe jetzt das foto gepostet
und auch noch dass hier das hat jetzt
2100 news nach sieben minuten und diese
leute haben jetzt gerade schon
geschrieben wir sehen uns nur zwei
stunden bis gleich
so etwas klappt haben wir haben jetzt
gerade 19 uhr ich glaub ich habe das so
um viertel vor sechs gepostet das heißt
vor einer stunde ungefähr 1 stunden 50
minuten als es ist doch gar nicht so
lange her das problem ist wenn man bei
snap chat umso weiter man halt oder umso
mehr es nun bekommt ich kann auch mal
zeit immer noch die chats öffnen das ja
blöd wenn wir wollen vielleicht auch mal
ein video ist oder so und deswegen fange
ich jetzt schon an wenn wir gerade auch
genau halloween also die beiden sms
gerade 13.000 news und dann haben wir
einmal 376 screenshots und 251
screenshots schon viel also ich bleibe
euch die beiden fotos noch mal ein das
war einmal das hier und da war es halt
so ein bisschen soja war er wieder fällt
und dann aber hier das zweite und ich
glaube da haben die meisten gedacht
eltern meint das ernst also es ist
natürlich schwer zu sagen wie viele
leute mir daraufhin geschrieben haben
aber ich würde mal so schätzen also das
geht ja eigentlich die ganze zeit so
runter keine ahnung 1000 1500 jahren ich
sitze jetzt natürlich hier um das mit
euch zu öffnen vielleicht auch mal so
ein zwei wörter warum ich das video noch
mal gemacht haben also erstmal natürlich
viel mehr reichweite und im zweitens
einfach diese message über zu jetzt
finde ich sehr wichtig weil ich wirklich
so komplett gegen rauchen bin dass ihre
kleinen schlingel wenn jetzt vielleicht
das 13 seite oder so auf keinen fall
damit anfangen ja genau und jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt auf die rezension
schaue ich glaube das hat eher damit nur
wenig zu tun so den ersten städten nicht
geöffnet habt ich dachte du wärst gegen
rauchen hör auf mit dem das ist scheiße
du solltest ein vorbild sein für andere
aber nein du nützt es aus und du zeigst
ihnen ein schlechtes vorbild ich bin
enttäuscht von dir du bist kein besserer
mensch wenn du deinen zuschauer wo zwölf
jahre sind sie sehen sich als vorbild
traurig dass das macht also über deine
rechtschreibung müssen wir euch nochmal
sprechen aber jetzt finde ich eine sehr
gute einstellung wieso rauchst du du
bist schon oh folge klappt oder nicht er
doch auf mit dem mars sein leben kaputt
was ist das für eine sprache alex bitte
nicht höher auf das ist nicht gesund
bitte von du nicht auch noch an bitte
und dann 17 minuten später bitter aber
man muss sagen wenn man sich dieses foto
anschaut das sieht schon echt cooles
oder ich meine so mit dem filter als ich
habe es bis jetzt auch schon 2 mal
gelesen auch schon wieder so ein
experiment das heißt der einmal andere
erinnert sich eventuell das wird sicher
ein gutes wie ich
wir wissen dass du nicht raus mach uns
mal ins neue video wir sind deine drei
heftigsten fan girls
oder kennt sich für unverantwortlich
ausrufezeichen die soll klar sein dass
du für viele ein vorbild bist und
verantwortlich
ja das gehört sie hat es sehr sehr gut
zusammengefasst das ist sehr schädlich
man kann dadurch krank werden deswegen
fand gar nicht erst an ja bin jetzt
rauchen was
ich weiß nichts finde ich cool
findest du nicht
glaubst wie das nicht erst seit
halloween feiern
ja schon eigentlich wollten wir schon
auch botschaften den marlboro kaufen
dann geht es rund
du sollst ein vorbild sein fick dich
ernsthaft
vor allem so sie schreibt vorbild wird
dein ernst von dir bin enttäuscht aber
es wahrscheinlich nur für ein video
besser youtuber ich bin das so
unterhaltsam junge mann höher auf voller
sie nicht böse aber das ist nicht cool
erst sage man raucht nicht in den videos
aber läuft bei dir der esa das ist doch
nicht ernst gemeint das ist halt jetzt
so schade diese ganzen videos und so die
halt vor einer stunde schon geschickt
wurden die kann ich jetzt halt irgendwie
nicht mehr öffnen oder ich muss halt
megalan runterscrollen hier haben wir
noch um mein gott eine zigarette rauchen
ja nee das ist nicht gut im jahr darauf
hören was gehört wenn du das siehst
brauchen nichts gute diese zeit waren
rauchst du oder ist das wieder ein prank
wie damals mit kiffen er läutet das
finde ich echt so gemein von youtube ne
ich hab da einfach ein video gemacht
drogen genommen irgendwie und das hat
auch gepasst und ich musste da so über
meinen schatten springen dass ich sowas
wirklich mache und dann hat dieses video
so voll polarisiert und deshalb mega
abgegangen und dann dachte ich youtube
com das geht auf keinen fall das stellen
wir ab 18 aber wenn ihr 18 seid schaut
euch trotzdem sollte man muss sagen die
stimmen sind eigentlich wieder eindeutig
soll auch weil natürlich waren auch so
34 dabei gemeint haben echt cool was ich
zu diesem thema noch abschließend sagen
möchte ich glaube sehr viele jetzt vor
allem auf die noch etwas jünger sind so
12 13 vielleicht 14 vielleicht auch
schon 15 keine ahnung ihr werdet euch
wahrscheinlich jetzt noch so denken hey
rauchen damit fange ich niemals an ja so
war das in meinem umfeld im früher auch
und irgendwann kann die ersten partys
oder anhalt mann eine zigarette
angeboten wurde dann greift man dabei zu
probiert das mal und wirklich sehr sehr
viele machen es öfter irgendwann sind
sie abhängig und dann brauchen sie den
rest ihres lebens und eigentlich nur
weil man das irgendwann als jugendlicher
mal ausprobiert hat und da ist dann halt
irgendwie nicht falsche richtung laufen
ja deswegen gab es dieses video nochmal
ich hoffe natürlich jetzt hat euch
gefallen an unterhalten lassen wenn die
nichtraucher sei das wird mein erstes
video von mir was ich selber leike und
dania jaksic auf jeden fall ab und
instagram und wir sehen uns dann morgen
oder übermorgen wieder haut rein